- STUPID.
- SEE, I DON'T EVEN UNDERSTAND
HOW THAT'S EVEN
IN THE HORROR GENRE, DOG.
- RIGHT?
I MEAN, THAT'S THE LEAST
SCARED I EVER BEEN, MAN.
IT'S LIKE
A ROMANTIC COMEDY.
- IT'S LIKE A LULLABY, DOG.
- YEAH, FOR REALS THOUGH.
- PSSH.
- OH, OH,
WHERE YOU PARKED AT?
- OH, WHAT NOW?
- WHERE YOU PARKED AT, DOG?
- YEAH, I'M OVER
THAT WAY, BOY.
- OH,
YOU ALL THE WAY DOWN THERE?
- YEAH.
- WELL, I'M THIS WAY, DOG.
- OH, ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, DOG.
- ALL RIGHT. ALL RIGHT.
[eerie music]
♪ ♪
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
- WHAT'S THAT, DOG?
- I'LL WALK YOU
TO YOUR CAR, DOG.
- WORD, WORD, WORD, YEAH.
- YEAH, YEAH, YEAH.
- THEN I'LL DRIVE YOU
BACK TO YOUR CAR, DOG.
DUMBASS MOVIE, MAN.
- NAH.
- A DEMON CAN POSSESS
ANY INANIMATE OBJECT?
THAT'S TOO GENERAL
TO BE SCARY.
- YO, MAN, IT'S LIKE,
HOW YOU GONNA HAVE A DEMON
POSTING UP IN A TRASH CAN?
- I MEAN, YOU KNOW,
IT'S DUMB.
- IT DON'T MAKE NO SENSE.
- IT'S STUPID.
- YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
IT'S STUPID.
IT'S UNREALISTIC
IS WHAT IT IS.
- IT'S LIKE, I AIN'T GONNA
BE SCARED OF NO TRASH CAN.
[eerie musical flourish]
AND WHAT WAS THAT OTHER THING
THEY HAD WITH THE,
UH, THE DEMON PUDDLE?
- OH, YEAH, YEAH.
THAT WAS THE MOST STUPID PART
RIGHT THERE.
A DEMON COULD PULL YOU INTO HELL
IF YOU STEP IN A PUDDLE.
LIKE, WE SOME MORONS?
- I MEAN, HOW YOU GONNA SCARE
A COUPLE ADULTS WITH A PUDDLE?
- STUPID.
- AND THE DEMON GOT
THEM HELLHOUNDS ROAMING AROUND
EVERYWHERE, BRINGING HUMANS
TO THE DEMON ALIVE
TO BE SACRIFICED.
- COME ON, MAN.
[dog barking]
- THAT'S JUST STUPID!
- STUPID.
- YEAH.
- YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE--
IT'S LAZY STORYTELLING...
- YES, YES.
- IS WHAT IT IS.
- IT'S A LOT OF THINGS,
BUT SCARY IS NOT ONE OF THEM.
[eerie musical flourish]
- AND WHAT WAS
WITH ALL THEM
CREEPY KIDS AND THE WHISPERING
AND WHATNOT?
- OH, PLEASE.
- I MEAN, COME ON, DOG.
- PLEASE, DUDE.
- WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
- YOU JUST IDENTIFIED, LIKE,
THE STUPIDEST PART OF THE MOVIE.
[both laugh]
THEM KIDS--
THEM KIDS WAS TALKING ABOUT,
[breathily]
"I WILL STEAL YOUR SOUL.
I WILL SUCK YOUR ESSENCE."
[mumbling spookily]
- OKAY, YEAH,
THAT'S STUPID RIGHT THERE.
YOU CAN STOP RIGHT NOW, MAN,
IF YOU JUST WANTED TO--
PLEASE STOP!
- YEAH.
- 'CAUSE IT'S STUPID.
- IT WAS STUPID.
- IT WAS STUPID AS HELL.
- IT WAS JUST STUPID. WHAT?
- THIS YOUR CAR?
- THIS ME, DOG.
- YEAH.
[both sniffing]
YEAH, I HOPE
THERE'S NOT ONE OF THEM DEMONS
POSSESSING YOUR CAR.
[both laughing]
I'M JUST STEPPING
RIGHT NOW, FOR REAL.
- THAT'S STUPID.
YOU BEING REAL STUPID.
- I'M BEING STUPID.
- THAT WAS THE STUPIDEST PART
OF THE MOVIE RIGHT THERE, DOG.
- I'M THE ONE BEING
STUPID UP IN HERE.
- THAT WAS PRETTY STUPID.
- [laughing]
- THAT WAS THE STUPIDEST PART
RIGHT THERE, MAN.
THAT PART WAS--THAT MOVIE
WAS STUPID AS HELL, MAN.
- [laughing]
STUPID.
- THAT WAS
THE NOT-SCARIEST PART
OF THE MOVIE.
OH, MY GOD.
IT WAS STUPID.
- LIKE A DEMON COULD POSSESS--
- I MEAN, IT'S SO STUPID.
- THAT WAS SO STUPID.
- IT WAS PRETTY STUPID,
THOUGH, DOG.
- OH, MY GOD,
THAT WAS STUPID.
- IT WAS PRETTY STUPID.
YOU KNOW WHAT, MAN?
I'M--SHIT, I'M SORRY, DOG,
THAT YOU HAD TO WATCH THAT
DUMBASS NOT-SCARY MOVIE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
- MAN, YOU KNOW,
THAT'S HOW IT GO.
00:02:54.441,00:00:00.000
[eerie musical flourish]